I went to college I went to London
College of Fashion I did the two-year
hmd theatrical makeup wigs and
special-effects makeup and mmm and yeah
so I that's I did the course there I was
late starter but a hairdressing I always
was a hairdresser so I had a good
grounding in hair although I wouldn't
say that was my strength and probably
the least thing that I enjoy out of all
the media
I prefer makeup and prosthetics but
obviously I do everything but yeah I've
started off as a hairdresser and yeah I
was just very lucky I guess because I
was the last I think in second to last
year that the government was sort of
helping people to have grants to the
ones I would never have afforded the
course at the time to be honest and
that's how I kind of got in into it was
it was during the course and also
meeting I guess Paul hire who I was
interested more in the prosthetic side
so I met Paul and sort of formed a
friendship and worked with him quite a
lot and then gave me sort of my
inspiration really for sort of seeing a
bit more he's know so much you can do
with makeup and then I wanted to take
things further with a collaboration of
makeup and prosthetics so that's kind of
where it led to
oh I mean there's millions isn't there I
mean absolutely absolutely millions i
one of my favorite films I love lo mein
rehne Margot you know foreign film
period drama beautifully done
Oh God I mean I respect every I respect
all the great people have done period
dramas I have to say I take my hat off
to you know Christine bundles Jenny
Shakur Lisa West crop you know all the
all those great designers that have done
period drums John Archibald you know
they know all those only one that can do
does period drama
I mean of the work that goes into though
into that is just phenomenal anyone that
stands to work like that
there will be they've made the people
that more influenced me you know stuff
like that doing a good job on because I
know how what it takes to do the big
crowd rooms and put a big piece of work
together
I think you've got a really love what
you're doing be passionate about it it
is kind of yeah you've gotta love what
you're doing I think you've gotta love
working with people I think you know it
is nerve-racking sometimes you know
because you've got quite a lot of
pressure on you being sort of a head of
department I think you've got to have a
nice nice team around you could people
know nice people
that can bring something to the project
too and and you know a mutual respect
for each department it's a whole family
isn't it films about you know it's about
coming together not about just about
your makeup it's about working the
costume working about production and
bringing the sum of the whole together
your little part of the cake aren't you
at the cherry I think makeups the cherry
possibly you know costume gets a big
thing doesn't you know and then them and
then you're the cherry on the cake and
also the actors probably more concerned
with this to the face the close-ups
isn't it how they look their confidence
you know - and and doing a lot of
character makeup - is it's all about
capturing an essence of the character
you know with what you design whether
it's the facial hair whether it's the
scar whether it's the tattoo or whether
it's the the hair you know it's all
about adding that little little detail I
guess you know